nightmare you're a dog person not a cat
person I'm saying I would like a
hairless cat like a sphinx I think
they're cool this shit in a box in your
house perfect situation piss in your
house I'm gonna change my toilet to be
Roman fuck yeah I'm gonna shit a bucket
yeah they shit in a box but that's a
great things gross sometimes my dog's
crap on the carpet if they're you know
irritable but cats are weird man cats I
don't have you can trust a cat do you
trust some cats you have a couple cats
don't you you got a fucking zoo I'm so
jealous I want to come over and just pet
everything in your house two of my dogs
died recently oh I'm sorry we didn't
last I guess it was probably almost a
year now
it was Marshall sad uh he didn't
understand what was going on
he looks like he's just pure joy and
happy he is all the time he's the
happiest daughter was he's so he brings
me joy I just started following one
mister he's so happy follow your dog on
Instagram he's my buddy he's it's so
weird
well you can see you guys have a
straight bond he's so affectionate do
you run him off leash in the morning
when you go oh yeah yeah no tickets you
know he's been he's got tick medication
that he's taken but we have caught him
with a couple of ticks home without all
that luxurious hair these ticks are
probably like was drunken match he he
loves it though he's never seen anything
in his pure joy as that dog is like
running through the canyons ah he just
loves it he's so happy so how do you
keep him so clean I mean I know you got
that like Joe Rogan experience money but
he is luxurious called water well I mean
everyone else just have water and I've
seen these mangled beasts they really
don't and they wonder why they lash out
yeah Marshalls not like if for cats when
you die cats will start eating your face
in like 16 hours dogs made if I don't
really that long yeah they probably wait
that long to read them yeah they love
you a little bit more they won't eat you
right away I don't even know if Marshall
would eat you I think you'd wake I
wouldn't even know what you were
probably wouldn't understand it he would
just keep throwing balls at you just
rolling him over to you just wine my he
woke me up yesterday was a fucking
really annoying whining it was decides
to get up